[Music]  so  [Music]  b  [Music]  [Music]  uh  we condemn any and all attacks on  humanitarian workers and assets  and remind again all parties of their  obligations under international  humanitarian law  all parties must ensure the protection  of civilians  and that all humanitarian assistance  provided by the united nations  is provided according to humanitarian  principles  [Music]  it looks like right now that the  government is admitting that they're not  in the same position that they were last  week  prior to the launching of offensives by  the tplf  and it looks like they are going to  withdraw back and  think of a few of uh further plans  especially because  the tiguay uh people's liberation front  did not announce that they are going to  accept this unilateral ceasefire  declaration they did not say that  they are willing to hold back their  flies and that they're not going to  attack  further positions and try to retake more  areas in the region  you